من وجهه نظر معينه فان نتائج لوزانا واضحه
لان تركيا التي نعرفها اليوم لم تكن لترى
النوره دون لوزان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ان لوزان هي سند الملكيه لتركيا وقد كانت
بلا شك حجر اساس مهما للغايه في تشكيل
تركيا الحديثه واقامه جمهوريه تركيا كدوله
قوميه
ان النقطه التي ادركت فيها القوه الغربيه
ان معاهده سيفر عام 1920 كانت حبرا على
ورق كانت حقا النقطه التي طردت فيها قواته
كمال القوات اليونانيه الغازيه من ازمير
وهددت بخرق المنطقه الدوليه التي تم
انشاؤها تحت شروط سيرفر في اسطنبول
والمضائق كانت تلك حاله مرعبه حقا لقوتين
تقفان وجها لوجه في جنان قلعه في اواخر
عام 1922
[موسيقى]
منذ التسعينيات بدانا نرى بعدا اخر اصبحت
لوزان تقريبا جزءا من نظريات المؤامره في
تركيا
في بعض استطلاعات الراي التي اجريت اليوم
يعتقد 40% ان هناك مؤامره كبيره في لوزان
يتم مناقشه نظريات المؤامره هذه في
المجتمع التركي اليوم
وباختصار لن ينتهي الجدل حول لوزامي